[Music]
Hey what is that what is good how you
livin how you doin
it is left NGO in New York City and Sims
in Orlando for the NFL owners meeting
and I just saw him on set with his best
friend Kyle Shanahan Sims how's the
weather in Orlando homey oh it's good
literally just did that work I saw it on
Twitter Sims there's these things called
the internet that you can really see
everything interesting maybe one day
I'll work for one of those Internet
company Internet companies also at the
end of this podcast we are gonna be
having Jerry Ferrara aka turtle from
Entourage he's doing a lot and I just
want everyone to know that I've gotten
to my new t-shirt
I'm the stugots now whoever made this
from the Leba [ __ ] fan base I am going
to put a fight between Jerry Ferrara and
stugots and we're gonna see who the real
stugots is Sims so you go down there and
then Odell Beckham News explodes is that
the number-one topic you're hearing down
there I would say so it's certainly the
number yes it is there's no doubt about
that I mean between that and some of the
pass interference rule changes and
things of that nature those are the main
conversations yeah but I do think the
Odell Beckham jr. thing let's go is got
a lot of people's attention so let me
tell you what let me bring everyone up
to speed and then I'll tell you the
stuff that's been happening it came out
a few days ago owner Mehra said quote
I'm tired of answering questions about
Odell's behavior he knows what is
expected of him and now it's up to him
then after the jpp trade Mara said that
no one is untouchable which made
everyone went wow even O'Dell okay Ian
Rapoport of NFL media came out on Monday
morning and said that Beckham is not
expected to quote set foot on a field
without a contract extension and then I
just got the BR app alert again
subscribe to the BR app that says the
Giants are open to dealing Adele Beckham
for at least deals that include at least
a first-round pick
one we got a lot of tweets this morning
people are saying yes it's finally
happening Oh Dells gonna hold out but
I'm curious as all of this information
comes out now Sims where are you with
the Giants Odell relationship because
our camera guy Gabe is is very
distraught right now the Giants fan
yeah well he should be distraught I'm
just wrong I'm a Giants fan - I mean you
know that I don't think my dad played
for the Giants 15 years so they're not
my you know diehard
team that I root for every week because
I have other relationships but I to me
there's so many different angles to talk
about here with this situation I think
the first thing is I am glad Odell
Beckham jr. said he drew a line in the
sand yeah I'm not gonna do it unless I'm
compensated fairly I mean if last year
didn't teach you that lesson then what
does right I mean he he broke his leg
it's probably gonna be used against him
in negotiations this year right well
we're not sure we haven't seen if you're
back to full speed so that alone tells
me yes could grow Dell Beckham jr. he
knows his value he's gonna play the
owners game now the other thing is that
the first thing I thought is maybe this
is the New York Giants way of scaring
Odell Beckham jr. maybe this is their
way of going you know I think if we
maybe you know threatened to trade him
and take him out of the New York City
area and the limelight maybe he will
fall in line a little bit better I'm
sure let's go they're sick of talking
about them I get that I understand that
but part of the reason they talk about
him so much too is some of their own
doing are they going to take some
responsibility for what right if they
would have paid them if they would have
paid them none of this would be
happening right or if they would have
paid them last year - they wouldn't be
have to do worry about paying 20 million
dollars yeah it may be you know 17 in
years right at 18 years something in
that room so I listen I get both sides
but I say this Odell Beckham jr. is
arguably the best offensive player in
the sport other than some of the
quarterbacks that are out there he is a
game changer we saw that from two years
ago when the Giants got to the playoffs
he was a game changer last year even
though he got hurt every single game he
was catching touchdowns right and let's
not forget that he almost lost his knee
in the Cleveland game right there
preseason right go along with
broken ankles so again the risk is
tremendous and I would say the risk is
tremendous for the Giants too because
they you know hey listen the Giants
gonna realize that this can be in ten
years people are gonna look back to this
and go damn you guys traded away the
Jerry Rice of your generation you traded
away one of the greatest players in the
history of the sport at a position that
is of prime value and I can promise you
there's gonna be plenty of teams I have
had coaches that already come up to me
today really asking yes what are they
asking you oh well do you know anything
about Odell Beckham jr. has any of the
players on the Giants told you anything
about him you know what you're known and
what have you heard about him so you
know if the Giants gonna tangle this out
there I can promise you there's gonna be
teams that are called them with an offer
here within the next 24 hours I don't
know many how many players would fetch
more attention than Odell on the open
market I mean this is the my mind the
most marketable player in the NFL
it's the largest shoe contract ever
given to an NFL player he is
internationally known we should have
known this was coming when Gettleman
came to the Giants the Gettleman that
cut Steve Smith the Gettleman that
traded Josh Norman large personalities
and the gentlemen and the giant way
seemed to clash a lot I have a question
from for mr. Mehra mr. Mehra says I'm
tired of answering questions about
Odell's behavior if we were to take the
three-second video that came out
recently where there was some mysterious
subjects and materials in there what
else has Odell really done to question
he's celebrated by doing a dog pee in
the end zone he was on a boat party that
he didn't really organize and there was
a more veteran wide receiver on the team
and Victor Cruz who if you're gonna play
is playing on anybody it's probably the
guy that's been there the longest he
hasn't done any off the field issues I
don't understand what is the New York
media at all at fault for this because
they're the ones that are constantly
asking him these questions that is said
he said I'm tired of answering questions
about Odell's behavior it sounds like
he's tired of being asked
questions and that's leading to them
being tired of O'Dell yeah I do I think
some of the just the overall attention
the superstar magnitude that just
surrounds Odell Beckham jr. I'm sure
does weigh on the owners look and I
understand the Mehra family and what
they want you understand them more than
most III would think so yes
and there are traditional Irish Catholic
family so then why can't they see that
this guy is generational I need to
explain this before you answer that
question you know said that Jerry Rice
comment if you look like oh he's not
that good I'm still shocked when people
don't think Odell's the best receiver in
the NFL I want to read some things to
cement why we feel that Odell is the
best wide receiver in the NFL we might
have to make that amendment by the way
number one he's the fastest wide
receiver in NFL history to 300 catches
he's the only player in NFL history with
200 catches in his first 30 games he's
the first player in 51 years with 30
receiving touchdowns in his first 35
games he's in the last 53 years he has
more receiving yards through his first
35 games than anyone has had in their
first 40 games he's the only receiver
with 3,000 receiving yards or more in
his first 30 games though pace that he
is going at is Jerry Rice these
statistics and his saying what sim said
is not hyperbole that's how good adele
is and if you trade him because you
don't like that he's becoming too much
of a distraction you need to know what
you're giving up this is not a top five
top ten this is a top two when he's not
two and he's all in one and it's O'Dell
right listen I'm glad you brought out
those stats because I try to say that
all the time do you like just go look up
the stats I mean this is the guy that's
breaking record while it is it's wild
and all even further you know listen
Jerry Rice he's a man but I'm just
telling you Jerry Rice I was alive I
watched Jerry Rice don't play against my
dad at playoff games as I was growing up
he was not as good as Odell Beckham jr.
at this point of his career
I'm just really there's no other way
around it and I'll say this too you know
here's the guy that's capable
and offense like we talked about so many
times I mean here we were two years ago
they couldn't even put points on the
board unless he made a big play and it
was oh let's think about the cowboy
Sunday night game
I got a stat for you I got a stat for
you you want to know Eli this is Eli
with Odell and without Odell this is
compliments of Bill Barnwell with Odell
he's got a quarterback rating of 91.5
and his touchdown interception is 66 to
29 without Odell Eli's mayonnaise
quarterback rating is 75 and his
touchdown interception ratio is 14 to 14
been like come on yes
like come on that says it all and I'll
even further that to say this I mean me
my friend the people I know around the
NFL I think a lot of them sit there and
just go well man imagine if he had an
offense that actually I mean it was the
crappiest offense in the sport let's not
forget about this they lined them up in
one spot and it was oh you double
covered well we still might throw it to
them Oh a single covered well we'll
definitely throw it so so I think those
are things that everybody has to take
into account to an Eli Manning certainly
Super Bowl winning quarterback but not
in the conversation knowing the 20 best
quarterbacks in this or anymore
No so you add that along with the fact
that the crappy offense what would he
even be capable of doing and some of the
other creative offenses in the sport I
think a know people have to ask them and
I think what in my opinion at least it
would be earth-shattering gramming
game-changer he could be of course not
only statistically one of the best
receivers ever but really like separate
himself from the rest of the pack here
is the left go plan if I was running
public relations and marketing for Odell
Beckham jr. here's what I'm doing number
one the Giants have already made moves
in which it seems like they want to win
right now they go out and they get a new
left hacker and solder they make the
trade for Ogletree they've kind of made
comments that they think they're gonna
go for it by keeping Eli they're going
for it they can't win it all unless
you're there Odell so we're just gonna
stay silent that's the first thing we're
not even responding to any of this
second thing we're gonna do is something
that left go likes to call the Instagram
push once a week Odell we're gonna put
out video of you training on
Instagram because if I know anything
it's when people see video of people
training they go and that guy's really
working hard
remember when D'Angelo Russell got
traded to the Nets and he put up that
video of him working out at 3 in the
morning and people were like oh man he's
grind in Odell one a week remind them
that you care and the last thing is I
would just keep using the phrase the
balls in their court because it is Odell
has already stated what he's going to do
I am going to sit out
Odell go do the Zeke go to like Bora
Bora and just train because don't even
come back until they make you an offer
you're Odell is done like the Giants are
only going to be talking themselves into
a corner if Odell plays this right as he
should he just witnessed his best friend
one of his best friends Jarvis Landry
last preseason do exactly what the team
wanted he didn't hold out he came to
every pre-season training camp practice
he was involved in the team he was
involved in the in the franchise and
what do they do they franchised him and
then they traded him like he was worth
nothing and they even talked bad about
him on the way out the door so if I'm
owed a I just got hurt last year so I
know to hold out I just watched my
friend go through this I'm not going to
do this and now the Giants are saying
they're willing to trade you my man
O'Dell
chill out don't do anything and wait for
that phone call that's my advice for
that right now yeah well I think that's
a good good advice that's all I can do
it man don't just chill out you got like
you said he's got a work hard and I
think that's the course good things that
we have to like continue to I think show
people as our duty as the Sims and let
go podcast the players ha yeah to point
out that again okay I know what Dell
Beckham juniors not perfect I understand
that and I do wish that some of these
antics that he's pulled off you know hey
I could have gone without him peeing in
the end zone in Philadelphia that was
not needed without this vibe the video
that went viral you know over in Paris
for him if he does want to be that
superstar LeBron James faces the NFL
type guy he can't do that kind of stuff
so I will say that that would be my one
piece of advice Bertha O'Dell but let's
not forget this is anybody I know
in the NFL that's been a
this guy Odell Beckham jr. he and
everybody has the same common message he
works hard he practices hard and he
wants to be one of the Great's of all
time not just like some good player that
just was had a flash moment so I've had
multiple people tell me that and I think
really his results speak for themselves
what does Brandon Marshall say about
Odell yeah that's one of the persons I'm
referring to exactly right I mean you
know yes he would be he would be you
know public supporter number one three a
guy that many times says assured me that
no this guy yes he might be
temperamental a little bit because he
wants to win but there's no meanness or
malice to this guy it's not like he's
getting in legal trouble let's just
remember that the worst thing he's ever
done is proposed and got a kicking that
pregnant okay I mean and so I'm saying
it's insane like tio went through this
too is like tio did nothing off the
field people just thought he was too
cocky and arrogant and I don't
understand how that impacts it and
everyone says that Odell is a much
better teammate than Terrell Owens was
would you trade if you're the Giants Oh
Delta Cleveland for the fourth pick and
the 33rd pick so that the Giants would
have to 433 and I don't know what the
like 34 so you have liked it like two of
that in the top five in the first round
yeah I would I would I would consider it
because then you could take sake one and
a quarterback maybe right yeah I mean
listen that would be that would be a
steep price for sure if you guys mean if
you if you gave me that yes I would even
her Odell Beckham jr. who I think is one
of the most talented guys I've ever seen
in my life
wow I would consider that because you
know those are the type of picks at
first and four and if you really know
that there's players there that you like
in those positions right you know they
can just set up your organization for
the next 10 to 12 years along with you
know you might knock it out of the park
with those two high picks in the second
round as well
Sims how do you when when someone says
to you yeah but you don't want to
allocate that much money to a Deever
receiver how do you respond to that well
I mean
so okay I don't even have a response to
that I don't I don't know really all
superstars in the NFL are pretty much
divas to a degree I don't think people
realize that receivers are tough
personalities deal with yes we know that
but I don't know Pittsburgh seems to be
doing okay with Antonio Brown don't they
I mean he thought he was doing Facebook
live in the locker room I was argued in
the Odell Beckham jr. has never done
anything that bad
I mean Odell Beckham pewters didn't
throw the huge gatorade bottle all over
the sideline in a temper tantrum Antonio
Brandon the Baltimore Ravens game right
but it's just again it's not a sexy
enough subject what was your question
what the hell is my answer
no you answered that and then the other
thing that I was saying was just about
the trading oh I know that but uh oh
yeah allocating that much money to a
wide receiver okay you know again I
don't have an issue with it and and and
if a guy like Sammy Watkins Susan get
paid 16 16 and a half million dollars a
year and he's not even in the same
stratosphere as Odell Beckham jr. then
listen we all just have to get to the
point where we have to get used to NFL
players are finally getting paid big
money and this is one of the best
players in the sport one of the most
notable has the best notoriety of any of
the guys in the sport he's a game
changer he can win games by himself and
I have no problem paying him 20 million
dollars a year all right you're down
there they're changing the catch rule
does it make sense to you can you
explain to me what it is now like I
don't even get it yeah okay it doesn't
make sense I do think it's gonna be
easier for everybody to digest the
public everything I think it's gonna
make it a little more just back to
football roots okay and and let me just
say this before we even dive into that
listen I think some of the biggest
problems last year about the catch rule
we're not really about the rule I think
it's more about like the guy that
overturned some of those catches that
shouldn't have been overturned so I do
think the NFL is to fix their process a
little bit too but right now what's
they're basically saying with the catch
rule is get 2 feet down and make a
football move and then the third part of
it is is a little bit of subjective
which is always going to be some part
subjectivity to this rule and okay if he
can't take the step right and he didn't
extend the ball and a football move
would he have had the time to actually
do that right let's just think about a
receiver who maybe catches the ball he
turns real quickly like with a
two-footed like jump turn around ran
he's going okay where am I gonna go am I
gonna make a move this way here am I
gonna make it move this way then he gets
tackled and falls to the ground like
okay that was not a football move he
didn't take two steps he didn't reach
the ball out but he had the ball for
like four seconds in his hand securely
and he sat there and then got tackled so
we're gonna call that a catch I think
that's the the easiest way to explain
that rule I just think it's going to
take the going to the ground part of the
conversation out of this and I think
that's what a lot of people are going to
enjoy about it the surviving of the
ground will no longer be a problem Dez
Bryan catch would be a catch Calvin
Johnson catch would be against Jim James
touchdown would be a catch Wow I mean
those fan bases I would be so pissed as
changing but it man so I got a chance to
meet three possible top 10 picks last
week I did a shoot with Old Spice and it
was Roe Kwan Smith Derwin James and
Quinton Nelson and that day that we hung
out Quinton Nelson actually had dinner
with the Giants last week but man
Quinton Nelson is a large large human
man like his shoulders he he's built
like one of those fire hydrants where
and I'll say this Derwin James is a lot
bigger than I thought - like Derwin
James is one of those new prototype long
armed Loring long leg yeah like Seattle
safety corner guys and ro Quan is like
if you looked in the dictionary of like
what a middle linebacker looks like he's
just like the prototype like everything
is symmetrical but man that a Quinta
Nelson it was cool man they were like
asking me they're like where do you
think I'm gonna go like blah blah blah
blah blah and I realized I told them I
said you guys are lucky like all the
cities in the top ten are cool cities
like if you end up in a Chicago or a
Denver or a New York like yeah that's a
dope city like the worst one is
Tampa and Tammuz not that bad of a city
but they're probably all gonna go on the
top 10 or San Francisco hey I mean yes
you're I mean you're right about that
they're all good cities they're all
going to be definitely in that top 10
range Quentin Nelson hey let's go I'll
go back to the story that I think you've
heard me say before but you know when I
started getting this like Notre Dame
pregame halftime show with NBC Sports of
course you know I had to catch up on the
team of Notre Dame and I turned on the
film and I was like man who is this left
guard that they just keep opening up
huge holes and gashing people by and one
of the first interviews I did about a
Notre Dame and NBC they asked me about
the linemen and the course again about
Mike McGlinchey and Michael Gucci is a
he's a borderline and the first round
type pick right somewhere between 20 and
40 I would say but I came out I was like
man this Quentin Nelson is the guy I'm
really impressed with he's like a top 10
top 15 picked and people like what how
come he's a guard overbought but I mean
you said it he is don't like a square
piece of iron is as good a run blocker
you're gonna see ever come out in
college football he's a better pure
guards and Zach Martin who most people
would say Zach Martin's the best guard
in the NFL right yeah well he's a yeah
he's a better pure guard coming out of
college in Zach Martin was big the
speeder quite as quick to play left
tackle but as a pure guard he is a
better prospect big picture I think it's
interesting to watch all the big guard
contracts from Norwell to Pugh to
Richburg and then to realize that we
used to have guys switching from guard
to tackle because they wanted bigger
deals but now they can stay at guard and
still get paid in the NFL it wasn't that
way five years ago no it was not that
way but I think you know this is again
something you and I have talked about a
little bit with all these freakish
athletes at the interior defensive
linemen
you know whether that's an Erin Donald
the Fletcher Cox Michael Bennett when he
moves in there and passing situations I
think teams are seeing the value and
having these good interior offensive
linemen these guards that the guards or
centers that can you can go okay you
know what we know this is a really good
defensive tackle but this guy can block
this guy man-to-man and yes handle them
and not be overpowered and now we can
lock our running play the way we would
like to
on the chalkboard we can actually do it
on the field because we don't have to
worry about our left guard getting run
over by Fletcher Kok Simms went back and
for the first time in his evaluation
life he watched all of the quarterbacks
how many more games for each man I'm up
to five games of each the costing is
five games of each not even six games
for some of the island I got the watch
I've never done this deep of a dive the
quarterbacks like I said it's a unique
year you said it I've never gone back
and really had to watch I didn't have
all the tape I wanted to bail the milk
yeah he the first time around but I got
to watch every third down past from the
years Wallach drives every interception
so far so he's seen it all I want to do
this on Wednesday when you're here in
person
because I think this is going to be big
I have to explain to everybody when it
comes to certain things in life
especially with sports you should trust
the people that you know know what
they're talking about and I've worked
with Sims now for four years and he's
been right about the quarterback pretty
much all four years so there have been
some changes to the top five I am NOT
gonna get into it now
Wednesday is gonna be locked and loaded
Sims was texting me more than he ever
has this weekend and I could tell that
you're excited I am excited I'm glad
you're waiting til Wednesday though
that's a good good head coaching call by
you because I do want to be there in
person with you so we can have the
discussion yeah I actually want you I
want you to read my notes - okay I
always you when you read my notes and
read them back to me sometimes it makes
me think a little bit differently than
maybe what I thought about reading them
or or you find a certain point that
maybe I forgot to talk about that you'll
see in my notes that I go oh man yes
that's great I'm glad you brought that
up so I'm glad for doing it in person
all right so we're about to call Jerry
Ferrara do you have a question that you
want me to ask him gosh I'm so mad I'm
gonna miss turtle man because I he's not
here yeah okay like I think he's a
pretty big like New York sports man - so
you know I really just wanted to talk
about how great New York Sports is and
how shitty Philadelphia Sports is it
just kind of rub that in on you the
whole time all right so I love Entourage
oh great New York is [ __ ] Philly all
right cool
how much longer you there for I'm here
I'm here till tomorrow afternoon very
cool
I'm about to go fly to San Antonio great
good it's been great seeing coaches yeah
how was Kyle right Kyle was great I mean
I got you know course got to see coach
Jon Gruden again we talked we had some
good conversations about what he's gonna
do with this offense this year all right
write all of this down because I want
all of it Wednesday yes I mean I was a
little scared when I walked by Jim
Caldwell on Tom Coughlin I thought for
sure they were gonna like [ __ ] me
or say something about how dare you talk
about Blake bortles
oh my I made it so yeah it's cool though
it's great to be down here all right
awesome
go have fun I'm gonna go talk to turtle
and I'll see you all Wednesday pal all
right peace out homies I'll uh I'll see
you Wednesday have a good show you know
don't [ __ ] this interview up man come on
thank you for sins you got homie perfect
all right Josh you're back there you
wanna holler at Jerry Ferrara so here's
what people don't know I'm gonna give
Jerry options of topics to answer
questions we're gonna flip this and then
also one of the options is me and him
teaming up on stugots very excited very
excited so let's see if we can get him
on here
what's he promoting Josh hang to my
email okay hello and welcome to the
meeting mmm your passcode followed by
the pound or hash key and I'll connect
you see this is the secret sauce that
people don't normally hear perfect
what's up Jerry how are you man Adam
left go bleacher report dude how's it
going Adam are you really I don't know
if you are are you really that excited
perfect because here's what we're doing
Jerry we are flipping the interview I'm
gonna give you a few topics to choose
between so you select which question we
get to now here's the thing I have a few
cat
gouri's I have four categories but we
can only get to three so one of the
categories you're not gonna pick is that
cool yeah that sounds good jeopardy yeah
like it is first thing I want to do is
the reason that Jerry's with us is the
Pringles versus cheese at crunch classic
celebrity basketball game so I do before
we get to the questions Jerry do you
have game who is your pro player
comparison and what should we expect
from that event okay I do have game or
at least I should say I definitely used
to have game I am getting up there and
I'm an aging veteran now because I'm off
the bench and get you buckets I've
turned into I got my old game working so
the mid-range game is tight
I don't really drive anymore out of fear
of getting hurt and I think what you can
expect from me in this game is everyone
shoots threes that's what's in vogue
right now I'm gonna I'm gonna find my
spots on the three-point line I'm
looking at the rosters and getting
coached by Magic Johnson Wow can't blame
anything on my coach no and then uh the
big question mark is gonna be the lucky
contestants that have won the challenge
I get to play with us I want to get them
the ball early and find out what we're
gonna get out of them right away out of
the gate you sound like a young Bobby
Jackson like a six-man that comes out
there microwave score heats it up real
quick sets the tone I like that well I I
like to think I am a poor man Chris Paul
like winning I'm not saying I could do
the things Chris Paul does but I would
like to model my game after his that's
why yeah watching now it is I like it
alright so that again is going to be on
March 31st Pringles vs. cheese at crunch
classic celebrity basketball game
alright here are your four topics that
you get to choose from one philosophy
two sports
three Entourage and the fourth topic is
stugots question your relevancy as a
sports radio guest and I would like to
team up with you as the news to gods to
take him down so those are your four
topics out yes well let's just do one at
a time which one do you want to do first
entourage
of eSports or stugots question your
relevancy is a sports radio guest and I
would like to team up with you as the
news to gots to take him down
let's go right out of the gate with
sports let's knock out sports we're now
doing sports with Jerry Ferrara Jerry
the question is if you were the Giants
what would you do with Odell Beckham jr.
ah absolutely nothing I want him on the
team I I think he's gonna bounce back
really strong from the injuries last
year and hopefully the team in general
will bounce back from the three win
season so I would do nothing I want
Odell Beckham jr. on I want him on the
Giants so I really would not do anything
with them other than just to hear he's
on the trail book get him healthy
they're open just hoping that that III
just don't I don't I don't want that
follow-up question as a Giants fan is it
hard to wrestle with the fact that you
guys do it quote a certain way and that
way could prevent you from having maybe
the best wide receiver the NFL on your
team I mean yes and no I I really don't
it's hard to get mad at the Giants
they've given me so much joy in the last
ten years it really is hard to say I
don't like the way they do things but on
the other side of things yet like I said
there's there's certain players that you
just like I just don't understand why
they would even shop him around at this
point to be honest it does not I get it
your comment off at three and thirteen
season maybe everyone's on the block
right but can you really say that
everyone on the block I mean I don't
know I agree Sims by the way is in
Orlando at the owners meetings he wanted
to say that he loves that you're a big
New York fan and I'm a Philly fan and he
wanted to team up with you against me to
[ __ ] on Philadelphia but he's not here
so that Super Bowl was amazing you
listen there's a part of you that like
enjoying that how was the only team that
beat no I know stellar stellar season
stellar season and your defense won't be
my fantasy week so I can't be mad at
well then you're welcome by the way also
check out Gerry he has the bad
for business podcast it's really awesome
just consume all the stuff that he does
all right now three more topics we only
get to to either question about
entourage philosophy or stugots question
your relevancy as a sports radio guest
and I would like to team up as the news
to gods to take him down let's go let's
go on your eyes entourage I know we have
the producer his name as mother hen aka
Josh vendrick is the biggest entourage
fan in the world I said hey what
questions should I ask
he gave me eight and then settled on I
need to know what it was like working
with Gronk on set so do you have any
good Gronk stories from that episode I
do it was it was amazing I believe if
memory serves me correct this was a few
years ago so I think he came did his
stop he shot his cameo the guy was on
crutches in the cameo in the movie came
back like the next in the movie yeah I
believe he came back the next day
although he wasn't working and just kind
of hung out and Edelman was there and
the coolest thing I remember is we were
having the scene where Russell Wilson
was actually throwing us the ball on the
beach we're like messing around and then
when ground came over you almost saw and
this was actually right before the
Seahawks and the Patriots played it was
it was prior to that you can almost see
Russell Wilson looking at Gronk just
like man I'd love to have one of those
on the squad like there was like this
admiration of a quarterback looking at
Gronk the same might look like how does
anyone cover you because no one really
does very well Gronk is one of the
largest human beings I've ever seen in
my entire life yeah I mean there's a
picture of me him and Edelman and
obviously I'm the smallest guy in the
photo but like even like you've been a
guy like element is not a big receiver
know the difference it's just as a whole
other it's a whole other human all right
Jerry that leaves us to one more
question we're either going philosophy
or stugots question your relevancy as a
sports radio guest and I would like to
team up as the news to gots to take him
down which one will you pick well Adams
I'm gonna say first off you are really
good at what you do because if I picked
this new god thing and I go away from
philosophy I feel like we're going to
address it in that good and then if I
pick philosophy then it's almost like
I'm ducking the question so
job well done let's talk about through
that yes yes by the way the philosophy
question was what happens when we die so
it was gonna be tricky no matter what
cherry so here's what's - God said about
you last week and let me tell you I've
been waiting for him to misstep and it's
time Jerry here's what's - God said
God's right before that music played
through God's was railing against Jerry
Ferrara
why were you railing against that for no
good reason you were railing against
Jerry Ferrara unfair to Jerry and I
apologize in advance but what are we
gonna stop trotting him out as a sports
radio guest it seriously ought to Rogers
over like a decade ago the movie was a
complete flop what are we doing with
Jerry Ferrara still and why is gonna Dan
Patrick Joe so here's what we do Jerry I
think that you're technically more
qualified to talk about sports than
stugots I think that he's taking a shot
at you because he's self-conscious about
his actual ability to play sports I
don't see Stu gods in the celebrity
basketball game sponsored by cheese it
and Pringles not at all
I don't see him with a big-time podcast
no I see Jerry Ferrara with a big-time
podcast so if you'd like me the new Stu
got sinew I think we take it to the old
stugots and I just curious what would
you say to that guy who cannot hold a
candle to your sports wisdom was pretty
random I don't know I don't know what
fired him up that day if you looked at
why I was on the show to talk about for
tonight in gaming which he's got a new
gig working with with Nick's gaming
which is a pretty big deal a simple
Google search would have done him a
little bit I mean agrees I don't really
feel like I need to defend myself I've
been on a TV show for four years and saw
Entourage doing a couple of movies I
don't know it just felt like a very
random out of nowhere I mean I love
their show I love what they do so if he
wants to talk further I just maybe he's
busy I'll talk to him about some
philosophy and see why he just went
rogue and just started I mean the whole
beef with Dan Patrick and all that that
stuff was great it was great but why did
you have
take the shrapnel of a radio beef yeah
you got caught in the middle man yeah
you know what and and he's the one that
shot that shot and it's hard to go it's
hard to go back
heads up at him you know they got a
pretty large audience with a lot of
content to fill five days a week so uh I
just I guess I would just say it was a
random radio beat that I got thrown in
the middle of an innocent victim of a
radio beef man here you are just being
the absolute legend that you are and we
have these peons these miscreants just
heaving pebbles in your direction
not even boulders just you know in
cognition thoughts just throwing your
way I'm not gonna stand for it
nope that's because the new Stu gots and
Jerry Ferrara are teaming up Jerry just
quick question what does happen when we
die I surprise surprise Jerry can do
another thing that's two God's can't a
Google search Jerry I appreciate your
time my man keep kicking ass thanks a
lot I appreciate it I have a goin
brother and that is how the news two
gods came to be Josh was that okay great
super happy guys thank you as always
love you so much Sims we'll be back on
Wednesday we are going to be doing all
of the quarterbacks and his new rankings
and I'm telling you that they have
changed not drastic crazy changes but
there's someone from the bottom that's
coming near the top and it's going to
get wild Sims as quarterback rankings on
Wednesday want to give a special shout
out to Jerry Ferrara for doing that and
to gods just know that I'm here
and I'm coming for you Simza left go for
Simms shout out homies fender good
evening the lef koe man says good night
thanks for subscribing to the BR channel
on youtube thank you so much love you
and we'll holler at you guys on
Wednesday
[Music]